station 19 on ABC airs every Thursday at
9:00 Eastern Time the season finale airs
tonight starring in part this man J
Hayden good to see you sir you too
now you are wearing let me describe this
for the radial audience mm a loud rap
well I mean that's loud one let's say
loud Red Sox shirt button-down shirt but
um the best way to describe it it looks
like a Hawaiian Red Sox shirt it's got
all the things on it it's yeah things
like well this is old because the
championship banners are like from 1916
and 1906 well this is the one that
counts this is the the o4 one right
there in the middle is the the thing
that kind of started like the umbilical
cord was placed many many years ago
that's pretty much where it is but to
change change history now you are you're
you're a Red Sox fan since birth I'm a
Red Sox fan since birth because I grew
up in Vermont and it really if you grow
up in New England you are a Red Sox fan
but unfortunately or fortunately I am
NOT a Patriots fan which is not uncommon
for people in the Vermont New Hampshire
Maine area because if you have a
grandfather or father that was born in
the fifth we were living in the 50s or
60s the Giants practiced in Vermont
during the offseason so most of us are
Giants fans and then bill or Bills fans
were not Patriots fans because nobody
had cable TV back then uh-huh so we
couldn't get and so you just you decided
when you were younger you were exposed
to the Giants like the Giants were on
NBC and the bills were on CBS and I
didn't like Thurman Thomas and Jim Kelly
hmm interesting so also the Patriots
stunk for a long time I'm terrible they
were terrible and so a Grogan year as
some people wear their Giants fans know
very easy for my dad to also be like you
see that guy wearing 56 watch him affect
every play and you could watch as a kid
and LT would affect every single play
exactly so what was it like watching all
of I guess most of your
patriot friend fan finally get worse and
it get there well I mean get theirs
thanks to Eli twice over yeah I mean
might not have been very popular well
that sucks because most of the time when
you meet another Red Sox fan
they will transition to and those in
Pat's and and and you know suddenly you
go from being their best friend to being
like I actually love Eli and then it's
then the end of the friendship which
sucks because in airports it's really
awkward and uncomfortable mm-hmm when it
all gets down to it yeah because you
know when you meet a Red Sox fan you
know maybe a bro hug there's there's
some there's camaraderie yes instantly
and then they transition into the Pats
and then you have to be like I can't
stand Belichick mmm anyway so and both
conversely Jaden when you bond with a
giant fan inevitably
the page will turn to the twenty seven
time world champion New York Yankees and
I imagine that's another awkward moment
for you Stan looks like he hits golf
balls it's not even that that's what I
miss batting stance in professional
baseball he looks he has my golf swing
so what he has can I translate for you
what that conversation would have been
like had he not told Derek Jeter don't
trade me to the Red Sox I don't want to
go there I'd like to go to the Yankees
had he went to Derek Jeter and say
please trade me to the Red Sox if I'd
like to go there do you know how that
conversation that's not what happened
that's not what happened Oh John Carlin
I mean I can't even do the Boston XOR
censors wouldn't do a dumb song every
time he hits a home run yes I mean is
that Italian yeah come on
submit that you would be you would be
gaga over Stan I have no comment we're
very happy with JD Martinez love JD very
happy 350 listen to you guys listen to
you guys
sander hit went into the PI class nobody
that was amazing phenomenal are we here
no but hey look congratulations on
having the second best record in
baseball oh it's great there was some
giant fans when they find out that
you're a Red Sox fan must be like what's
your problem I basically don't get to
belong to anyone you know I don't get
the full you know Jay Hayden is an
island by the way that would be a great
name for your memoir Hayden isn't on Jay
Hayden isn't Islands true it's true and
then kind of like then I imagine when
when then then when you do bond with
sports and then you start talking shonda
rhimes I'm sure you get that you and
then they're like oh sure you unrest cue
me I'm like no that's not who I had on
from Grey's Anatomy years ago on the NFL
Network
anyway I just told her I'm like look my
problem is is that if I ever went to
your hospital and I was in trouble I'd
be concerned that you're too busy making
out with yeah flat lining and you are
making out to some Motown sound track
somewhere having sex in weird places
there's not work being done I get it I
was always concerned about that like how
a patient rate of success in yeah the
Grey's Anatomy we have time to fight
fires and save lives when we're just
boning each other
that's a rhetorical question we only
know the answer to the totally our
technical advisers are always like we
sit around and watch sports we don't
know what the hell you guys are doing oh
man but this is a big step up here in
the Shonda Rhimes universe to go spin
off on Grey's Anatomy and then you're
part of this world this yes this is an
interesting gig for you yeah on the
catch I was a sarcastic partner
detective person hmm and now I'm gay
firefighter and next I mean who knows
I'm gonna be possibly the president you
never know
some of it son Shonda Rhimes show the
president's making out with somebody
yeah I'll be making out no matter what
it is I mean that's part of the audition
yeah they're like you said the lines
right now are you gonna make everybody
up to speed on the plot wicked awesome
it's totally wicked my friends back home
really last night when you were making
out with that dude it was wicked awesome
I'm like thanks Leigh Travis Montgomery
the first male openly gay main character
in the Grey's Anatomy universe and
against in all seriousness though I mean
for Shonda Rhimes series this is serious
business in this town
certainly on ABC yeah congratulations on
being part of that thank you and so does
she have a fantasy league is there a
Shonda Rhimes fantasy league softball
team can we just get a softball team
well Jason George is willing to put
together but we got a you know it's we
don't have a lot of interest is what I'm
saying let's get a melon Pompeo isn't
jumping out of the woodwork you want to
talk about Boston accents
I know holy cow have you she's on a
central hunting she's amazing how do you
like damn Apple I mean she's I mean when
she shows up on set she's so different
than the character in television so many
curse words so many curse words it's
amazing that's right it I'm telling you
like whatever she's great
the only comparison is that whenever
you'd like would see a character from
The Wire talking in their normal like
Australian or British it's the same
thing for me when I see Ellen Pompeo in
a in an interview like whoa she sounds
like she's a Southie yeah she's she's
great she's fantastic
well look Ben this was a fun
conversation good to see you here on the
show thank you come back any time yeah
great you know come back any time I
won't wear this I'll wear my giant
starter jacket I'll wear my giant just
your starter Qi I got an old-school
giant starter jacket I thought I see I
don't fit in I'm not accepted well guess
what you fit in here because yachty by
nature is playing outside shortly here
we have to go out and saying have you
seen that situation that's it I see a
lot of setting up going on oh yeah are
you ready to go interview the mic I'm
ready to go all right good to see you
Jay Hayden hey Jay Hayden double zero is
it that's not for Robert Parrish yeah
some other cooler I think there's a
hip-hop artist in Atlanta that got the
first Jay Hayden handle so I'm Jane zero
zero well it's it just say it's for
parish yeah very good at Jaden double
zero check him out on Twitter and again
every single Thursday night in the
season finale airs tonight of station 19
on ABC good to see you sir all right the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience